we're back with the former and current
stars of the wonder years fred savage
and ej williams
and also joining us is tick-tock
sensations zechariah porter who has
account and welcome back zachariah this
is my favorite place to be i love you
here so much yeah thank you for having
me i'm so excited um i mean how do you
see what you do how would you explain it
i don't know i i love cooking i think
cooking is really fun i'm not terribly
great at it but i think if you can read
you can cook and i kind of found like my
love of cooking with my love of like
thrifting and found these old machines
that we're gonna use today and it's just
like so fun to see if they work these
are really good ones i promise you
they're going to work and i think it's
going to be fun to do it all together
and try them out if you're ready for it
because the wonder years takes us
through a certain time in life and
history zachariah take it away cooking
through the ages okay so this one's
first this is the great american popcorn
machine it's already on okay this is
actually from 1976. i found it at a
thrift store for twenty dollars i like
almost squealed when i saw cause it's so
exciting and then it's really simple
this is just some popcorn oil right
there
pour that right on there okay so freddie
why don't you grab the popcorn seeds
right here throw them right in there
right in there yeah right on top you
can't mess it up
beautiful great job that's it guys
that's all it was wait and so then you
put and then
is that of the are the holes is that
from melting butter so
my gosh you're so smart and the heat is
gonna drip it down onto the delicious
popcorn and it's you're you're smarter
than i am because my
initially made this video i didn't know
that i thought this was just for steam
and everyone's like put the butter on
top of it so i have no idea ej butter or
no butter on popcorn to be honest i love
butter i just hate it when people overdo
it like just because i love something
don't put it on it when i don't want it
there right i see that
yeah yeah yes well listen my first job
was at a movie theater and people love
butter they love a lot of things
happening here okay well the popcorn
popper is working it's magic yeah by the
way is this the time to put on the
butter yeah do you want
your butter popcorn
is this an occasion i mean i don't know
if this crowd likes butter or not so
please don't look at me like you disgust
me okay
while that's popping i'm i'm sorry i'm i
might be getting ahead of myself but i
think i see a i
what is happening with the onion okay so
this is the great american steakhouse
onion machine from 1990 something
mid-90s okay and i found one of these at
a savers near my house six dollars and i
i love it so much so it's exactly how
you make a fried onion that you'd see
at um like a outback steakhouse yeah so
before we do this i think the popcorn is
almost done i think it's like it's i
think it's pretty good i don't want it
to burn don't burn it perfectly right
okay
this is like a flipping the omelette cup
yeah it is so what i'm doing at my
kitchen i i kind of like
oh
okay okay okay oh
and you're right now you knew it i know
i know
you knew zechariah that it was time do
you want to put some salt on it oh no
yeah want to do a little salt okay so
right i have no idea how to use it
is that you do it i think i think i'm
doing this look at you guys this is a
workout ready let's just try a piece
real quick look at how cute this is it's
perfect it's beautiful
yeah
yeah
all right let's get into this onion
so if this one was easy this one this
one is moderate this is moderately hard
right so this is not the easiest one
i've ever done but it is very rewarding
so you know it's dangerous he rolled his
sleeves up yeah he's ready he's relaxed
so you take a vidalia onion a sweet
onion right you cut the top of it off
and then it comes with this amazing core
right so all you do is you stab it right
in the middle
yeah this is from 1998. so this gets a
little tricky at points but look we'll
get
[Applause]
so this is when things get really i want
you to do this i know i think you love
this the best okay you put the onion
there
put this on top
set it up beautifully match up the
little right there okay drew i just want
you to give you all your weight right
there and press that down really yeah
come on give it to e.j okay okay
because i'm being a good person and i
just it's the best part like you'll have
the most fun with this because this
looks like such a saturday night to me
okay
it does
all right uh
yeah i feel sad for this onion but i'm
not gonna cry but uh let's see
oh my god
you're beautiful
that's beautiful
it's perfect so good it's so good
okay so from here what you do is you
kind of like knock it out it gets a
little tricky because you don't want to
break the onion but yeah with movie
magic here we already have some set up
okay so right here
you would you would take it out of the
case right there and then you want to
float it in some ice water for about an
hour and that's how you're going to get
all those beautiful onion petals you're
looking for see that makes me not want
to eat it because it just looks so good
oh you're going to want to eat this for
a shower
i know i'm like a seagull with this
blooming onion i'm like okay so and then
from here
you do
you would do dry
to wet to dry this part you need to roll
up your sleeves this one this gets
really really messy okay um do you want
to do it oh go for it sorry no i wanted
to i thought you were suggesting i
didn't know if you wanted to or not why
dry then wet them back to dry that's
what google says and i'm not really sure
that's okay yeah i'm not really sure
either got it and then back in a dry
and then from here after this you'd pop
it in a fry later for three minutes on
its top flip it around on the bottom and
then after that
it's pretty much done and that's how we
have these here right now
you want to do that one i don't know
i'm a little stuck with it no i put it
there i'll put it there okay i'm gonna
can i try the blooming onion yeah maybe
i'll try the blooming i think we all
should try the blooming onion or the
awesome blossom you can't wait well yeah
i want to get on this yes okay you guys
go first fred didn't you intern with
like chef ludo who's one of the greatest
chefs like in the world i've worked in a
couple yeah i had a kitchen with him for
a little while yeah you're familiar let
me see this yeah
how how was that ludo's so frankie um it
was it was awesome i didn't do a lot
quicker get your hand in there i like
washer like going for like set up and
like
pit cherries for like two hours
like you didn't let me do a lot of like
cooking okay ej fred zechariah this is
just such a treat and such a pleasure
and um
you guys the wonder years airs on
wednesday nights on abc
back thanks to fred and ej
[Music]